I want to talk now with Jonathan Turley
who's kind enough to join us who
certainly has his perspective as a law
professor and dealing with a lot of
these issues to say the least so thank
you Congressman Comer now uh per usual
you know the FBI Jonathan he's going he
says the FBI has to be dismantled Etc
the FBI's admitted no wrongdoing let me
start with this they've admitted no
wrongdoing why would they writing in a
statement here sir quote The Bureau
regularly engages with private sector
entities that make decisions about what
if any action they take on their
platforms and for their customers after
the FBI has notified them Fox News
contributor Jonathan Turley uh what is
your reaction to that kind of statement
with what we know now from this recent
drop of the Twitter files
well you know Tammy what's disturbing
about the statement is it shows
absolutely no self-awareness of what has
already been disclosed I mean it's
showing utter contempt for the American
people the FBI could have said look we
find these allegations disturbing we're
going to conduct our own immediate
investigation to see if these types of
contacts went too far and instead
they're just saying well we did nothing
but correspond with companies that is
not what these new files are suggesting
they're suggesting censorship by
surrogate by proxy you have dozens of
FBI agents who supposedly were tasked to
go through social media you have 150
contacts with just one Twitter executive
giving lists of users that should be
banned including satirical sites there's
very little Runway left for the FBI to
continue to deny that there isn't a
serious problem problem here people I
think largely agree I hope that while
the the first amendment applies to the
government it also applies that agents
of the government so if the FBI uses a
proxy uses an agent like Twitter it's
still censorship it's still a violation
of the First Amendment
what's interesting here too and I I
think that Americans are frustrated
because with the FBI they seem whether
it was you know the Russian dossier hoax
you know their interference some argue
in the 2016 and 20 elections is that
nothing ever seems to happen are we
missing something that Congress can do
other than have reality television you
know committees uh you know every day is
there something that can be done
immediately especially with your remarks
about their statement which effectively
confirms that they seem to be fine they
knew about it they weren't outraged or
shocked what what are the options here
well obviously it's going to take some
time to build the type of case for
substantive change I don't think most
people are talking about dismantling the
FBI I think what the representative is
probably talking about was dismantling
these Troublesome components of the FBI
if there is a censorship program going
on and we do need to look at that but a
case has to be made this these files are
not just an indictment of the FBI
they're an indictment of Congress
Congress has shown a steadfast refusal
to dig into the censorship allegations
many of us have been writing about this
for years the Democratic members have
refused to pursue this and in fact
Democratic members have pushed social
media companies to expand censorship you
know in the very hearing where Jack
Dorsey apologized for the hunter Biden
laptop
debacle uh the the immediate reaction of
Democratic senators were to tell them
don't backslide on us we want more
censorship well now we have not just
censorship we have black listing we have
these shadow bands all of that is now
open to the public and so in some ways
musk has forced people to choose sides
and I think that some of the anger that
you see in the media borders on
self-loathing I mean they're having now
to embrace not just being censorship
apologists but blacklisting and Shadow
Banning and also lying because that's
what we've seen for the last three years
that's a lot to take on yourself and
still claim that you're a journalist or
you believe in free speech so it's going
to take a while but I cannot tell you
how long overdue this is we need to see
it all and hopefully the house is going
to pursue that
well great stuff and you have been of
course one of them this has been on your
plate for years and an excellent point
about Congress and their abdicated
responsibility or their complicitness
with like the Democrats I mean for those
of us who are classical liberals it we
used to be a you know a thank you
against the government spying on us it's
like we're in some kind of Nether world
uh Jonathan trolley thank you very much
for joining me tonight I appreciate hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else